y seguimos con nuestra serie dedicada a
los recicladores américa latina y españa
para descubrir las condiciones de
trabajo y vida de estos hombres y
mujeres hoy vamos a buenos aires en
argentina donde las mujeres lograron
ponerse en un mundo de hombres este
reportaje hace parte de la serie de
publicaciones resultado de la beca de
producción periodística sobre reciclaje
inclusivo ejecutaba con el apoyo de la
fundación gabo y latitud r
aunque los recicladores en argentina son
una comunidad exhibida e invisibilizada
como en toda latinoamérica en la ciudad
de buenos aires- su historia cambió
gracias a la lucha de cooperativas
lideradas por mujeres como cristina
lescano fundadora de el seibo la primer
lucha nuestra fuerte malas prácticas y
constructiva
y después bueno viene todo lo demás
rompimos un mito era un laburo de
hombres
y es el día de hoy que los empresarios
los compradores buscan a un hombre para
para hablar y se chocan con nosotras hay
quienes encontraron en el reciclado no
sólo una forma de vivir sino también de
conocer y asumir el feminismo como
jackie flores creadora del primer cuerpo
de promotoras ambientales en la ciudad
de buenos aires cuando me toca ser
responsable de la descarga una mujer
conduciendo a 40 compañeros entre
choferes y operarios fue una experiencia
que me marcó una experiencia valiosa
para mí para empezar a profundizar el
feminismo popular muchas son líderes de
cooperativas e intentan mejorar las
condiciones de los 15 mil recicladores
que trabajan en la ciudad y más de
150.000 en todo el país maría castillo
fue cartonera y hoy está a cargo de la
dirección nacional de reciclado
darle insumos que son de bolsones
guantes fortalecer con más sensación
para que ellos ese valor agregado que le
dan con láser ablín para mandarlo
directamente al industrial mejor próximo
en su lucha ellas lograron más derechos
para los recicladores pero aún queda
mucho por mejorar faltan leyes de
responsabilidad extendida que impulsa en
el reciclado con inclusión social un
mayor financiamiento para las
cooperativas de recicladores y educación
ambiental para que los ciudadanos se
paren residuos en origen